-Recently the New York City
Rent Guidelines Board
voted for the biggest
rent increase since 2013.
The board voted to increase rent
on one- and two-year leases
for nearly a million
rent-stabilized apartments
in the city.
-I'm glad you brought that up,
Meyers.
I hate to do this,
but I'm gonna have to
raise the rent on the studio.
-Oh, I'm sorry, everyone.
This is Late Night Studios
landlord Harvey Stool.
-[ Whistles ]
-What do you --
What do you mean
you're raising the rent, Stool?!
-Well, eh, you know,
through the whole pandemic,
I never raised the rent once.
-Uh-huh.
-But, you know, times are tough,
and you gotta do
what you gotta do,
and, you know,
I gotta make ends meet.
-Yep.
-And to be honest, I may have
heard you've been using the
studio to shoot a second show.
"The Amber Ruffin Show"?
Heard of it?
-Uh-huh.
-You know?
-Yeah.
-Alright?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Eh, no, no, no, no!
That is a violation
of his lease!
-Who told you we're doing that?
-Doesn't matter who told me.
I could have you evicted.
-Look, you haven't
really been holding up
your end of the lease either.
-How so?
-Well, I have a cartoonishly
large list of things
that need to be fixed
around here,
and you never seem
to get to 'em!
-Like what?
-Oh, I don't know. Let's see.
The handle on my dressing room
is loose.
One of the urinals
in the guest bathroom
has been leaking for a month.
The light on one of
the "Applause" signs
needs to be replaced
because I'm definitely
not getting the kind of applause
I deserve!
[ Applause ]
And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No! No!
-And!
I've seen a rat
running around the studio!
-Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There aren't any rats
in the studio.
-Oh, really?
Because look. There he is now!
-What?!
I ain't no rat!
-Then who snitched about us
doing Amber's show in here?!
-Eh, okay.
Maybe I spilled the beans.
But you can't blame
an egg like me
for trying to make
some extra cabbage.
-Scram, you,
or I'll have ya bumped off!
-Eh, alright, I'll blow.
But you haven't seen
the last of me, chuckle head.
-Get out of here,
you damn dirty rat!
-[ Cackling ]
[ Applause ]
-Uh...
Uh, the rat left a bunch
of droppings here.
-Uh-huh.
-Ugh!
Uhp. Nope. Sorry.
Heh. Just Raisinets.
-Okay.
[ Audience groans ]
It's just Raisinets.
Ho, ho, ho!
Okay, I got to go.
Unless there's anything else
you need me to do here, Meyers.
-Well, there is one more thing.
I had a pizza party for the crew
last night, we left some of
the crusts in the studio,
and now I think we have ants.
-I thought I saw a bunch of ants
in here when I came in.
[ Excited chatter ]
Oh. Yep. Yep. There they are.
Okay, ladies.
Shoo! Shoo, shoo!
Shoo, shoo, shoo, shoo!
Sorry. That was my fault.
After the show, we're gonna
smoke-bomb this place.
That should kill all of them.
-Who even told the aunts
we had pizza?
-[ Cackling ]
-I thought I told you to scram,
you rat!
-Ehh! Eat beans, Meyers!
[ Cackling ]
-Ah. More Raisinets.
[ Laughs ]
No. Nope.
That was not a Raisinet.
-Okay. Well, then.
That's disgusting.
-Alright. Ah, well, I gotta go.
-Okay.
-But there is one more thing.
-What's that?
-Ha ha ha.
This has been
a real silly sketch
we decided to do just for fun!
[ Laughter ]
-Did you, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you think there was gonna be
like a title card or something?
-Yep.
-Did you ask anybody
to make you one?
-Nope. [ Chuckles ]
-Seth Meyers!
-Oh, great.
Here come the ants again.
-You know, this feed is a lot
like that Geico commercial.
-Ah, didn't see it.
I had to sell my TV.
-Alright. Great.
-Don't miss
"The Amber Ruffin Show"
Friday nights on Peacock.
It's shot right here
in this studio.
-I knew it! Get out!
You're gonna get evicted!
Get out! Get out!
-We'll be right back
with Celeste Ng.
You're in my shot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪